What the elite have done is create
religion to control your energy.
>> Men wanted slaves, so they created a god
that approved slavery.
>> The Bible is a collection of deliberate
lies for the purpose of control and
manipulation.
>> God didn't write the Bible. Men wrote
the Bible. Councils, kings, politicians,
you know, the ones that tax the poor
people. They wrote the Bible, not God.
>> If truly the Bible was created by kings
and politicians, they're doing a very
bad job at promoting their propaganda.
Think about how much of the controlled
media is against the Bible and against
Christians. And it actually seems like
every other religion is off limits to be
made fun of except Christianity. Even
the Church of Satan sued the show
Sabrina over defamation because they
showed the Baffomet statue in a negative
light. How many music videos openly
promote Satanism? Concerts are literally
a satanic ritual. If the rulers of the
world really wanted to control people
through religion and the Bible, you'd
think they'd be promoting it a lot more.
Instead, the Bible is illegal in 52
countries. Afghanistan, Iran, China,
Cuba, Colombia, Pakistan, Philippines,
all around the world, people are
literally persecuted and killed because
they refuse to back down from their
beliefs. Now, tell me, how much sense
does it make that the rulers of the
world want to control people with the
Bible and yet they kill you if you obey
it and believe in it. Having the Bible
promoted in schools was considered
unconstitutional in the 1960s when the
Supreme Court ruled in Abington versus
Shimp in 1963. That devotional Bible
reading led by school officials is
unconstitutional. And in the military,
following complaints to the Department
of Defense prohibited placing specific
Bible verses on military themed dog
tags, citing the need to avoid the
appearance of official government
endorsement of religion, and even at
public spaces and events such as
baseball fields where you can't even
show a Bible verse on the field. So,
just think about that. The rulers of the
world are outlawing the scriptures, yet
they created it to control you. It
doesn't make sense, and it's illogical.
The truth is, the Bible is not just a
mere book that sits on your shelf in
every home in America. It's a collection
of 66 books written by over 40 authors
from all different walks of life, from
fishermen to kings. And the majority of
them were threatened, persecuted, and
killed for what they wrote and believed.
And these manuscripts, these ancient
scrolls were found all over the world
over a span of 1,500 years. And yet all
the writings from the Old Testament to
the New go hand in hand, perfect,
tightknit, and prophesy exactly the
world we're living in today. A world
where the government is the enemy. A
government that deceives the entire
world into obeying a certain form of
worship punishable by death. The Bible
is really a book to control us by fear
and make us bow to the governmental
systems of the world. It seems odd that
it would have stories like Moses freeing
the Israelites from the tyrannical hand
of the Pharaoh or the Roman Empire
killing our savior. We are told that
Satan is the god of this world. That we
battle not against flesh and blood, but
against principalities, against the
rulers of the darkness of this world.
The Bible is not some book that instills
fear in us and makes us bow down to some
governmental system, but on the contrary
tells us to obey God rather than man.
So, the next time you hear somebody say
that the government created the Bible to
control you, send them this